donc ici on doit bien avoir un sens
philippe portrait chaque année ariane
paris le gall en temps et la quinzaine
de boulot planté sur son terrain le
boulot peut couler beaucoup
des fois je vais ramasser sur un boulot
en ont donné deux par jour mais je peux
ramasser jusqu'à une douzaine de
l'étrange journée des fois propriétaire
de l'entreprise gourmet sauvage qui vend
des produits de la forêt québécoise elle
connaît bien des multiples usages que
l'on peut faire du boulot ya une
tradition de production de sirop de
bouleau et de consommation de sel en
choeur printanière qui remonte à il ya
très longtemps dans les provinces
canadiennes
on en consomme davantage qu'un produit
qui est un peu plus connu le sirop de
bouleau au québec par contre demain
vraiment dans l'ombre du sirop d'érable
la concentration en sucre de l'autre
boulot est beaucoup plus faible on parle
de moins d'un pour cent si c'est pour
cela que le logo l'eau doit être
beaucoup plus longtemps sans prob ça
prend beaucoup c'est beaucoup plus de
travail
on appelle ça de l'or noir c'est pas
pour rien il avoue être dans l'ombre du
sirop d'érable le sirop de bouleau gagne
quand même en popularité au québec
ces petites bouteilles que gourmet
sauvage ven 18 $ chacune partent vite
elle estime en avoir vendu pour 1200
litres dans la dernière année il ya
quinze ans les gens qui achetaient du
sirop de bouleau chez nous des as du
sirop de poteau sauve terrains classés
maintenant les gens voient se disent
assez curieux ça m'intéresse
ils achètent et y reviennent
aucune norme ou association n'existe
encore au québec pour régir le sirop de
bouleau
mais les producteurs sont de plus en
plus nombreux à se lancer
les giroux et clément buisson exploite
une érablière en bosse sur leurs terres
ils ont aussi beaucoup de boulot ils ont
décidé d'en entaillé 1200 temps qu'on a
commencé c'était à caudiès premier
avantage
la récolte de la sève de bouleau suit de
près celle de l'érable à la fin du gel
et avant les bourgeons foutu cette année
on a taillé boulot puis une journée ou
deux après le boulot des années à bhl et
fini son boulot avantage numéro 2 les et
clément comme tous les acériculteurs ont
déjà l'équipement requis comme ceux
concentrateur à osmose qui permet de
réduire la quantité doit bouillir en
concentrant les sucres l érable ce après
un prêt de 30 à 40 galons pour faire un
gallons de sirop
mais le boulot ça peut apprendre 440 pas
de boulot et troisième avantage selon
eux un boulot peut être aussi rentable
que érable ce qu'on regarde c'est le
beau frère de clément qui vendent leur
sirop en kiosque et sur internet
on veut plus un tour ne que les gens il
ya tant que sa nature qui a peut-être
une quinzaine d'années ça leur mandat
les ventes que plus de gens qui
connaissent a aussi eu le plus de
cuisiniers de plus en plus qui cuisinent
avec aussi le sirop de bouleau va
chercher des notes presque 2 mais
l'astre est caramélisée et puis à des
notes résiduelles un peu acide aussi qui
peuvent évoquer le vinaigre balsamique
avec un fond de café donc c'est très
très complexes comme spectra d'aronde on
va le travail et surtout surtout en
cuisine salée donc avec autant les
fruits de mer que le poisson on peut
aussi simplement l'utiliser en finition
sur des sales and sur des entrées qu'on
va proposer l'entreprise appalaches à
diversifier son offre
le deuxième produit ça a été un coulis
et rabelais boulot qui est un mélange
deux sirops avec un peu de crème et bas
sans lactose qui est un petit péché
mignon
l'attrait pour les produits du boulot
est aussi présent en europe est une
entreprise en profite dans bellechasse
cdl est le plus important fabricant
d'équipements acéricole au monde et
l'évaluent à un million de dollars ses
ventes européennes l'an dernier dans un
marché encore embryonnaire
l'intérêt du sirop on voit souple sur
wii dans les régions comme la finlande
la scandinavie je serais pas surpris de
voir éventuellement en france plus
intéressant le sirop mais présentement
c'est vraiment les au végétal qui qui
est vrai mais la bougie d'allumage qui
fait en sorte qu'il sert et l'équipement
de cdl est même utilisé depuis l'an
dernier pour recueillir la sève des
boulots de la forêt royale de chambord
dans le val de loire
capa sol assez fraîches sur le marché de
une cure comme de santé qui font
annuellement qui le lie à des terres au
niveau des commercial des grosses
entreprises qui veulent embarquer d'eau
moi je suis convaincu que ce produit là
est voué à un brillant avenir ici
l'érable restera roi mais qui pourrait
se plaindre d'une saison des sucres plus
longue et diversifiée